et les samu social souvent ils ont sorti
un chiffre c'est un viol toutes les huit
heures sur les femmes adorent
et c'est ça je te genre comment tu te
retrouves à la commission familial
compliqué de l'inceste et j'ai fui je
n'ai pas trouvé l'accueil que je
cherchais à paris je me retrouvais
dehors les premiers soirs je me suis
fait violer après c'était fini
c'est pas il ressort de d'aller chercher
de l'aide
mon sabre oil and sweety en même temps
mais alors 17 ans 10 septembre dont les
deux dernières années avec un mais voilà
c'est un témoignage très fort et j'ai
adoré cette jeune femme aux seins des
femmes sont victimes de violences c'est
en terrasse dans la brèche
claudio on sait que vous n'avez pas été
sans abri ne vous avez vu quand même la
misère de de très près avant voilà
d'exploser et d'avoir et je vous sens
vraiment heureux aujourd'hui on sent
vraiment que vous êtes heureux parce que
il paraît que vous avez fait la manche
dans le métro pendant deux ans ouais
tout à fait mais c'était c'était voilà
c'était c'était pour faire connaître
c'était c'était un moment papa super
facile voilà c'est un moment assez
compliqué mais mais on a été et puis
effectivement passé des sdf ça vous
arrive cette fois les mecs qui vidaient
leur poche je sais pas quoi restez avec
nous restez là il s'éclate à y passer du
bon temps et voilà quoi ça m'a apporté
une religieuse le regard des gens et
puis ceux qui t'aiment ceux qui n'aiment
pas ça nous a ouvert à beaucoup de
choses on venaient d'alsace quand même
que d'un coup tu te retrouves à paris
mais dans le métro donc tu vois il se
passe c'est pas le même monde c'est pas
la même planète quoi
voilà c'était à faire j'y retournerai
pas ça t'a apporté beaucoup de choses de
ce que tu es aujourd'hui en tout cas
c'est ça m'a rendu plus fort un peu plus
plus solide et puis ça va ça m'a permis
d'ouvrir les yeux sur ce que la vie tout
simplement parce que tu sais chez nous
on est un petit peu mais enfin on est
dans notre bulle en alsace suis senti
tranquille où je suis dans une campagne
menée voilà on est loin de tout ça tu
étais heureux maintenant qui sera quoi
je suis super heureux voilà je vis je
bosse chez j'aime les gens il ya du
retour il se passe beaucoup de chasseral
je suis très heureux bien sûr en tout
cas que l'audio tu le méridien onas
baume peine soit et et etops vraiment et
tu mérites ce que tu as vrai talent on
va pas se mentir claudio voilà il a un
talent énorme triste et je pense que tu
vas faire encore de longues longues
longues années de carrière parce que on
sent que tu quittes
et si on sent que tu kiffes qu'il va
faire tout seul c'est une équipe
d'amateurs du moment je pense à régis je
pense à ta mine et je pense à toute la
team vraiment qui est surreprésentée
voilà qui était déjà bien et qui m'a
porté sur les jeunes étalons